yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
your data is your business
protect it at expressvpn.com
democrats don't know how to talk
democrats are unable to take things that
would make
90 of people's lives better and sell
them to 51 percent of people whereas
republicans are able to take things that
make one percent of people's lives
better than some
51 of people their package of appeals
is more potent than democrats
like maybe we need to try and take
lessons from uh some of the appeals
they're making
and so one of the things i said on the
debate stage was like look you know one
of
the best sell for fixing health care in
this country
is like right now it's terrible for
anyone who wants to start a business
switch jobs or anything different we
already got the people we've got
the issue is the people we don't have
right and we have a sense of what some
of those people's values are
why don't you hear democrats saying when
we sent our boys to normandy
right they didn't leave one person down
on the battlefield they ran back they
put themselves in danger they picked
that's a that's what we do
that's who we are as americans and when
i'm president
that's what we're going to do on the
battlefield of healthcare
[Music]
all right guys on today's episode we
talk about
the ceo summit with the ceos the four
biggest tech companies going to congress
and we set up this conversation with
anon with some comments about our system
today why philanthropy's not working and
how we restructure everything from the
ground up
it's a long episode and is worth every
freaking second i was
riveted by this conversation andrew's
too humble to talk about how awesome it
was
but it was awesome enjoy it guys
[Music]
the four ceos of the biggest tech
companies in the world just went
and basically got grilled by congress
and andrew you watch the whole thing i'd
like to summarize it for yank speaks
listeners and why they should care about
this if you think that's relevant well
the summary to me was it's about
damn time uh but what i said
was that really each of these companies
needs its own hearing
i mean they each have their own specific
set of issues there certainly were some
themes that came out
from the hearings um one thing i will
say that i found humorous
was that a republican congressman it was
like why do my emails go to spam
are you like anti-conservative and then
a democratic congresswoman was like
my my emails go to spam too like we all
go to spam because we're spam
which i i thought was funny um so
uh to me the republicans being so
focused on what they perceive to be
anti-conservative bias i thought was
um a waste of time honestly like and and
that that exchange i just said
like summed it up for me
that that many of the these platforms
have been actually very conservative
friendly relatively speaking
um you know facebook actually is a
boycott right now
um in part because people dislike um the
decisions they're making
the most ridiculous stuff there were a
few things that i thought were
ridiculous number one is
each company took great pains to paint
itself as like a scrappy upstart
it was ridiculous where it was like
facebook opened up by saying like oh
we're not the fastest growing app
uh tick tock is it's like yeah
like or just like cherry picking
ridiculous categories
um and saying you know like 650 billion
tech companies somehow like this this
like uh
um upstart that's worried about um
that like these up-and-comers um
and then when the testimony came out
that they bought instagram
uh and the instagram founders were like
hey if we don't sell to them they're
gonna go into destroy mode
uh it was totally ridiculous that uh
that zuckerberg was like no
because it's totally clear that they
were gonna rip off whatever features in
sight uh and go after them if they
didn't buy them
um and so the fact that the instagram
founders knew that is not
uh i mean it like i would have
appreciated if zuckerberg had come clean
and been like of course we're gonna like
try and destroy like uh you know our
competitors
by taking their yeah what not except you
know you're not allowed to say that
um on the amazon side they focused a lot
on what was happening to third-party
sellers
which is a problem because it does seem
like amazon gets a lot of data and
sometimes
either advantages their own goods or
even just like
realizes hey people really like like
this type of item so let's just provide
them this item ourselves
uh you know like that like that that
does seem like it happens an awful lot
um on amazon but to me the missed
opportunity was
some of the anti-competitive stuff
they've done with things like
diapers.com
where uh diapers.com was up and coming
selling diapers right and left and
amazon was like hey let's buy you and
diapers.com is like no
and then what did amazon do just sold
diapers for like
you know steep losses and like nickels
on the dollar
and the diapers.com um started
hemorrhaging
and then diapers.com was like okay
[ __ ] i guess we're gonna have to
sell to you
um and so no one sheds any tears because
i think diapers.com got like six or
seven hundred million which at the time
was a lot of money but that was the kind
of thing that amazon does
uh and so it's the third party reseller
issues yes but it's also the fact that
they
do have a near monopoly
in online retail so those are some of
the big issues that came up
in the the hearing the to me the most
interesting thing was
it seemed to me that there's going to be
some kind of anti-trust action
coming down the pike uh them they missed
a lot of the data issues which in a way
i understood because
um there aren't laws concerning that in
the same way
uh you know this is essentially an
anti-trust hearing uh
but it seemed to me like we can expect
some
kind of anti-trust enforcement or action
where facebook and amazon are concerned
and then google and apple it's much less
clear right
so for context everybody was it was
zuckerberg of facebook tim cook of apple
sundar pichai from google and then jeff
bezos from amazon
um so and to me the republicans argued
the conservative censorship which i
think was a losing argument and the
democrats weren't just
anti-trust like you guys are monopoly
what was crazy to me
and so you've talked a lot about
facebook but i'm curious your thoughts a
little more on unpacking what your
thoughts are on amazon
so what they seem to do like the
diapers.com example is good but the
other one that's fascinating to me
is they let's say they're
selling flour tortillas on amazon or
food's probably bad example they're
selling headphones
and there's three competitors on there
or there's one product on there
and there's different data coming in and
how many people are buying them and at
what price and why people are turning
away and they have all this data
and then they can take that data and
then make their own
product at the perfect price at the
perfect
the perfect positioning and sell it next
to all that other stuff so they know
and they know in real time they get a b
c d e f test
that and they know in real time where
are people going to convert and it's
it'd be one thing if and jeff bezos was
saying
well and there's no rules for other
retailers to do this
and that is true but macy's or whoever
you want to say he's comparing himself
to doesn't have one that real-time data
and two
there are other retailers for people to
go to but if you want to sell a product
you have to sell on amazon now so
what are your thoughts on one your
thoughts on that in general
and two how do you regula how do you
regulate that
on a bigger picture and um and then
specifically
the single biggest thing you would do is
you'd say guess what amazon no more
house brands
you know like that that would be
something uh that would solve the
problem for sure
amazon would look at that and say that's
not acceptable because they make a ton
of money
um and so to me that is a more effective
means of enforcing real competition is
that you can't
have your house brand and run the market
at the same time
um if you have a near monopoly on like
online
retail uh and marketing itself yeah the
marketplace itself
yeah and and so and so jeff talked about
how
it's like oh we made this controversial
decision to like let other
sellers into our market and like uh you
know
people thought it was a bad idea and
like we made all these other sellers
rich and then you have these sellers
saying that it's like a drug and like as
soon as they get you hooked on amazon
and then they
end up destroying you just the way
heroin does i mean it's very dark so
some of the stuff that people were
saying uh yeah and i
i think that uh amazon did
what you would expect them to do
amazon's this ruthless efficiency
machine they figure out the headphones
they're selling they're like hey how
much those headphones cost
what like you know they got some crazy
profit margin
um and so then they just started
substituting their own goods over time
um that that's what's been happening and
the best way to
solve it for it would be to say look if
you run the market then you can't house
brand it
what do you say to someone right now
that's listening this is like okay yeah
these are definitely problems like
amazon's gauging us whatever it is
but their gut reactions like boohoo like
you're talking about the ceo of
diapers.com losing some money you're
talking about rich entrepreneurs like
losing to
the other rich entrepreneur like i i
think
to me this and you've taught us for like
how it cuts into like our creative
enterprising nature and hurts
entrepreneurs like what do you say to
someone that that
that is not in this game like how is it
affecting our day-to-day lives of
of the average person well this is the
tough part zach is that they're probably
not
amazon is not gouging you in that
example like
if anything they they're probably
slightly undercutting
whatever you were going to pay for this
yeah we're benefiting they're gouging
diapers or whatever they're getting
diapers.com they're gouging those other
headphone manufacturing companies that
build up their little operations
uh and a lot of it is that the small
resellers are often very poor uh you
know barely making ends meet it's not
like
a mega corp it's you know in in many
cases
it's a small headphone shot yeah or even
in some case an individual
mom and pop because some of the
resellers on amazon are you know just
people random people who you know set up
a shingle
but the net benefit to consumers is high
it's one reason why amazon wins so much
so the so the pain is a little
more indistinct because if you're a
consumer you're like i get
headphones maybe even cheaper and then
there's some company i've never heard of
that is suffering but who cares i just
want my headphones
uh and and so if you're
the government you look at it and say
well how do i feel about this like what
is the purpose here
is the purpose to have a robust uh
competitive landscape if that's the case
then this is totally messed up
um is the purpose delivering headphones
as cheaply as possible to as many
consumers as possible then
this is okay uh and that's one of the
reasons why
amazon has been able to do what everyone
wants for so long because the
traditional antitrust framework was
around price
uh the thought was that if you're
anti-competitive you're gouging people
and amazon has managed to be
anti-competitive and not gouge people
actually save us money right i
one of the things you've said before is
you can't take the sledgehammer you need
to take the scalpel
and i agree with you this is generally a
positive thing but you need to have six
hours
with apple you need to have six hours
with google you know yeah because
they're so you can pay apples oranges
yeah
and you probably need a different
regulatory framework um because price is
not the answer
for sure anti-competitive behavior is
yes you can get
um have meaningful uh
curbs and limits based on that certainly
one of the big things is you have to
monitor and uh prevent them from
acquiring certain types of
businesses where the the reality is that
it's very bad for innovation if uh
facebook can just gobble up any startup
in sight
and you end up with just one social um
media network at least for most consumer
activities
um and that stuff's anti-competitive for
sure so
there are certain things that you need
to be able to do better
so last question on this and we'll move
on but
because i imagine a lot of people
listening this did not watch it or maybe
watch a recap
i and so my summary for this is these
guys
did not look phased at all they look
cool calm collected
do you my thought is they went they did
this [ __ ] and then they're gonna go
back their yacht or their private jet
and not give a [ __ ] about this going
forward do you think anything comes of
this like are they just like shoe fly
don't bother me over time
well certainly most of them uh don't
think this is gonna be a major
threat because they haven't seen
government actually drop the hammer
um i mean it's been 25 years since
microsoft
um yeah but i i think in this case there
is something coming out of dc
um it may not be the hammer like it may
not be like a break them up
uh fully um but they're going to be some
antitrust actions coming out
particularly towards facebook and amazon
uh and so like but you know if you're
worth whatever 180 billion dollars like
you know you figure you'll be able to
manage it
if your company would be fine like over
a trillion dollar company or like okay
this might suck for a little while but
we'll survive and flourish
[Music]
here at yang speaks we think that our
data should be ours and right now our
data is getting harvested right and left
by tech companies marketers data brokers
and one way you can change that is by
using
expressvpn vpn stands for virtual
private network which is fancy corporate
speak
for it's like you're on the internet
someplace else
uh so they can't find you you could be
like you know out of country
you know what's wild is netflix actually
has different shows and movies
like depending it's true so it's like
you're logging in in italy or whatnot
and sometimes you'll get some different
programming
now there are lots of vpns out there but
expressvpn
is top rated by wired and others it's
ridiculously fast you hit a button
and then essentially it's like you're
logged on someplace else
where no one can find you and so if this
is something that you want to make part
of your
internet hygiene you can use our link
right now at expressvpn.com
yang get an extra three months of
express
vpn for free that's expressvpn.com
yang so you can surf safely and
in the privacy of your own habits
without anyone looking over your
shoulder
honestly i really love this thing
because i'm not good at installing apps
or little
widgets or trinkets on the computer but
expressvpn dude you just
literally press a button it's fantastic
i can't i can't
i've i'm unable to screw it up which i
love so check it out we get a good
discount with us expressvpn.com
yang
[Applause]
every time i come on and talk with you
andrew i want to talk about my favorite
tweet
um of the past week that you made and so
this was by far my favorite you tweeted
this
you said if you succeed within a system
it's hard to see how [ __ ] up it is
um which i loved and then i i also
um there's two reasons i love this one
because i think there's a um
there were some conservatives that that
argued against it or just
brought up a counterpoint and then i
also segues into our conversation or
your conversation with anon which which
is on this episode
so ben shapiro who is a polarizing
conservative figure but you've been on
his show um and he was reasonable to you
and
he said um well that was a reasonable
response so to your tweet he said and if
you
don't succeed within a system it's easy
to blame the system so anecdotal success
or failure does not dictate
whether a system is good or bad so
a pause there elaborate more on what you
mean by
this system and frankly you're talking
about the perspective
around the system whether it's good or
bad what did you what did you mean when
you tweeted it
well it applies to a lot of things
unfortunately in american life uh
but yeah um but i tend to think about
things
through an economic lens uh and so we've
had this
punishing economy that has turned on
most uh
working americans over the last number
of years uh and
to ben's tweet um you know it's like i'm
not really an anecdote guy i'm a data
guy
you know like if you can see that uh
housing and education and healthcare
costs have gone up and up and your
income hasn't changed then
that's probably going to make people
very miserable and
you know if you let's say made a lot of
money
uh during the this last number of years
you tend to think it's like okay well it
worked for me so
maybe it's still working okay or or the
the fact that you know it's like you oh
i worked hard it's like well
you know my cleaning person works hard
too and like they're not exactly
um killing it so so like that there's
like a
natural human reaction to think that
uh one if you're okay then others are
okay and two
uh if something worked for you
then it's working uh and you could use
the economy which is what i was thinking
about it for but you could think about
it for just about anything like our our
quote-unquote meritocratic educational
system um
which i think ends up informing our
culture uh in
many many respects um there
there are just so many imbalances in
american life now
and the folks at the top are often
insulated
from from them the best of them realize
it's like okay just because i made it in
this system let's call it silicon valley
it's like
you know are there some very very smart
hard-working people who become very
successful in silicon valley of course
um you know as silicon valley been
somehow some like pure meritocracy where
all you need is a good idea like not
really you know if
if you look at like you know i mean if
you look at the backgrounds of
a lot of these founders and and uh you
know you see some very very consistent
themes
um and to to me the big
issue is that you can believe in
individual agency and autonomy
and self-development which i 100 believe
in and also
look up at the facts and say uh well
like our institutions and structures are
not actually helping people
flourish and succeed which i 100 uh uh
believe in yeah it's not black and white
yeah they're not somehow mutually
exclusive it's not like if you try and
fix the system you give everyone a
license to just like throw their hands
up and say
you know like uh like take care of my
stuff for me i mean that's not the way
it goes
but everyone just wants to do better in
my mind
and we've just made it difficult or
impossible for many many people to do
better
i was on wall street i just remember
this like
classic almost idiom from
the executive directors and managing
directors above me where they would
they wouldn't always say it this way but
it would be implies like if you work
hard like i did and play by the rules
keep your head down
get into good school and work your way
up you'll be successful like me and
that's like something you get
in that world and i
like a quick story when i was in i went
to a public school and um
said kids from all different income
backgrounds and i never this kid alex i
was after football practice like 6 30
and i'm going home and i'm like where
you going he's like i'm going to work
i was like what do you mean he's like
well how do you think i pay for this
cell phone and these shoes
and so me i didn't grow up with money
but
relative to the system i was loaded in
the sense that i had two parents that
love me and they gave me a crappy cell
phone but more importantly they let me
go home
at 6 30 after football practice and have
time to do my homework
right um and alex did not have that time
um alex was working at dunkin donuts and
baskin robbins till
you know one in the morning and then i
don't know when he did his homework i'm
not sure
um and so
to me like that's something that the
people at
ubs like just never saw like they just
don't see that right and alex is working
his ass off um but it's different like i
mean thoughts on is that is that where
you i mean that's kind of what you and
and on talk about right where
like the people at the top don't
understand how broken the bottom part is
or the disparity there like what are
your i mean
thoughts on that or you know i think
what what alan and i talk about
um is in large part that like we've all
been brainwashed
into thinking that like the system is
good and then
we uh lionize folks who are at the top
of the system being like how did you do
it how did you do it and then they're
like here's how i did it and they like
sprinkle
um the sprinkle the the goodness and
wisdom
uh of market world um and his
profound observation which is totally
correct
is that that's [ __ ] that market
world is actually
um like a very specific set of
uh institutions with specific rules and
if we look to
that universe to save us we're [ __ ]
and he's right and so you need some kind
of
different pull of thought of ideas
of solutions because the folks who are
served most amply by a given situation
are very very unlikely to be like this
situation is terrible
tear it up you know like like that like
they might suggest cosmetic tweaks
uh and we're well beyond the cosmetic
tweak
zone like we're in the overhaul zone
and so when you try and figure out okay
what does the overhaul look like
you probably don't necessarily want to
take your cues from the folks who
have climbed to the top of
the of the world that you
that you need to make significant
changes to one of the things you guys
said was
that for some reason if you make a lot
of money we like think you're a genius
and you were like i think you might be
if you make a lot of money you might be
dumb and like a whole bunch of stuff and
we probably shouldn't be relying on your
wisdom
on like social policy or health care
policy which i think
is true right like if you built like you
made a bunch of money selling
widgets you're selling cheetos like you
probably don't understand the
intricacies of the federal reserve or
god knows what you do in government yeah
you'd have a narrow band of expertise
that
i'd be highly interested in if my goal
was to do what you did
but outside of that domain like you know
you may
you may actually be worse off than most
because uh
in my experience if you're worth a
billion dollars
no one around you actually ever
questions you or tells you no
so you might be like my gosh so you
might be really really
uh awful in your judgment on a whole
host of things uh and so i i think
anan's
uh core thesis of his book winners
take all um was so powerful uh
and it was so needed and timely
there's this myth that private
philanthropists can actually help and
make massive change
and i'm here to tell you because i i
spent three years
at my job at on wall street was to deal
with the wealthiest philanthropists in
the world and help them give money to
charity
and i'm here to tell you that a lot of
them are good people and they mean well
but they're not solving anything they're
not solving
squat um and somewhere they can't but
the other way
um like there's so many like natural
ways to screw up your philanthropy like
if
you worked 30 years like making money
selling insurance
and you want to give back you probably
won't put your name on something so
you're going to start your own thing
like there's so many there's way too
many charities people putting their name
on stuff because it's their legacy
and so it's less about solving the
problems many times it's about giving
back and feeling good
but there's nothing necessarily wrong
with except it's not you know the wrong
is
that nothing gets solved yes so we we
talked to wes moore about that
where you can't solve a trillion dollar
problem with a million dollars i mean
that that's what like a lot of a lot
and in a way you're like well at least
you know you gave the million like
that's kind of good
right but but then um but you don't want
to fool yourself
um and and so i think that's
um that's one of anan's core
ideas uh i was so excited to sit down
with him he
he was uh he's someone that i've known
for a long time but i haven't actually
had a chance to connect with him since
really the campaign launched
yeah he's um this is one of the good
ones like you guys like
you're cut from the same cloth you've
seen the same problem i think from
different
perspective and experiences and you guys
just riff um this is a fast and i'm
passionate about it because i've seen
i've seen the people at the top i've now
seen the people at the bottom of the
campaign like we
we you need a systematic change you
gotta like you always said rewrite the
rules the economy rewrite the rules of
the game like that's the only way this
is gonna get solved
you know and it's conversations like
this that drive you in that direction
all right guys
andrew's conversation with the nand is
coming up right after this break
[Music]
so yang i when i was a kid my brother
used to have this t-shirt
and it was just a bunch of soccer balls
on it and on a
on a plate with a fork and knife and it
said eat your veg to balls
and for some reason i always think of
athletic greens
when i always think of that shirt when i
think of athletic greens
because you're supposed to eat your
vegetables but in my case eat your
vegetables which is a dumb segue into
this ad for athletic greens
well we're all we're all in our house is
more than normal
uh we might be cooking more than normal
or
eating poorly more than normal hey man
i've i've gained everybody's gained like
the kovid
10 to 30 in my opinion some like if
you're if you've been working out
excessively and eating really healthy
like kudos to you you're a superstar
in this i said a while ago that anyone
who maintains
a higher level of physical fitness
during this time should just get more
responsibility because they're like the
most disciplined
yes self-directed person they should be
promoted they should be hired in our
government
all of it yes yes there are new leaders
and one way to
put yourself in that category is through
athletic greens
because you drink it it's energy
it's healthy it's nourishing it feels
great
you're getting your body all this stuff
that you know it's not getting otherwise
you know like it like it's not in ritz
crackers
i mean like like the it's not in the
pizza i've been ordering
yes even when you throw veggies on that
pizza it's still
not doing the trick uh so athletic
greens does do the trick it's a life
changer
i've got it in front of me right now
drank it this morning
whether you're trying to get more energy
have your
gut health improve which is really
important your immune system
if you go to athleticgreens.comyang we
got a special offer receive the free
dsk ii wellness bundle with your first
purchase that's up to a one year supply
of vitamin d is added value
when you try their delicious and
comprehensive daily all-in-one drink
so go to athleticgreens.com yang
and you know you'll feel better in no
time if you order this stuff and start
making it part of your everyday routine
a lot of these things actually taste
nasty and athletic greens i can say
objectively taste pretty good
like i throw it a little water and chug
it it tastes great so you get the free
d3 k2 wellness bundle which is basically
like hyper athletic greens that they're
going to throw
on top of your order which is a pretty
awesome
deal it's a year's supply of vitamin d
to throw in there so check it out
athleticgreens.com
[Applause]
it is my distinct pleasure to welcome to
yang speaks
the author journalist
activist commentator political thinker
massive influence on me and my thinking
ana girdardas welcome it's great to to
reconnect
likewise so good to talk to you you and
i you know what's fun is i
read your book which had a big impact on
me and if you haven't read it if you're
listening to this
uh anand's book winners take all was
to me one of like this seminal the
seminal tract
on how far we've all been brainwashed
into what anand calls market world which
i thought was a great name it's capital
m
a capital m and capital w oh and capital
w
so capital m market capital w
world uh but i one of the fun things is
in reading your book is like i felt like
i was a little bit
a part of your origin story not really i
was more like a witness to the origin
story
so uh you and i have been friendly from
sort of like new york
uh circles and then you and i found
ourselves in aspen for this aspen
institute gathering
and you're like one of like the henry
crown fellows which in the aspen
universe is like
like the knights of the round table sort
of thing
like you know you got gathered in you
should know they they um
had me apply and rejected me
it's probably for your benefit so we're
at aspen you're one of the knights
um i'm there as like a guest or an
observer i
you know and there are all sorts of
different people
uh there and we're getting a
presentation
from someone from goldman sachs about
some something they're doing
around like rebuilding small businesses
it might have been something like 10 000
small businesses
and rooms filled with very powerful
influential people and i'll never forget
this you
stand up and you're like are we
seriously listening to this goldman
sachs presentation
at this gathering where we're supposed
to be trying to figure out how we're
going to rebuild the world
and then this bank and institution
that's been complicit
in a lot of the depredations of the last
number of years is literally just like
telling us about like the good stuff
they're doing
and you could hear a pin drop in that
room it was a big room with a lot of
people
and i had to say like standing there i
was like
that guy has so much
guts because standing in this room
saying that even though it needed to be
said like i loved it so much and i think
afterwards i was like dude that was like
the most baller thing i've ever seen but
it truly was because like it felt like
you were
throwing uh like a fly in the ointment
or like a rock
into the the gears and like there are
these giant gears of
happy talk that we were all going to
engage in about the good
things people were doing and some of the
things people were doing there were
legitimately good
uh but you're like hey fyi like
this particular stanzas [ __ ]
and and by calling that out as [ __ ]
like it made you question a lot of the
other things that were going on
it's so interesting you know i mean at
first i remember
hanging out with you in that godforsaken
mountain town but i did not realize that
it was at that
goldman sachs lunch which was actually
a year or even more before i gave the
speech
in aspen that would result in the book
and so but you're absolutely right and
it's so interesting you pick up on that
that was actually the origin moment and
i've never actually talked about that
before even though it's on youtube
like that was actually the origin moment
because i had been selected
by this fellowship the henry crown
fellowship
and to be very clear you know you were a
little more relevant in that
world like i was really not i was a
writer this was a fellowship mostly for
business people who were looking
to do be more than business people to
kind of think more about societal issues
move in the direction of thinking about
the public good
in their own modest corporate way
but as you also know from your life
experience a room full of 20 business
people
is human ambien i mean it will just put
everybody to sleep
business people are profoundly boring in
general so
there there was this notion of you know
sprinkle a couple people who are not
business people
into every class of 20 or so people
artists
writers circus performers whatever i was
one of these people i was the indian
spice
in my class and so i'm in this thing
and you know i would love to be able to
sit here and tell you a story like from
the moment i got there
i was outraged and i saw everything that
was wrong with it and i fought
but that's not how the world works at
least not for me
that is not how the world works for any
of us it takes a long time to see things
right i mean this is sort of why i'm a
writer like the art of seeing things
is like such a difficult art
particularly when there's such great
incentives
in the form of beautiful vistas and
delicious wine to not see them
right and so i was very much in the
in the kind of um myopia
the pleasant myopia of that world the
first couple years and i would
basically meant you go to aspen once a
week you read plato and aristotle
and gandhi and you discuss things with
these people about making the world a
better place and it seemed
fine it didn't seem i wasn't
particularly convinced that it was going
to change the world
but i wasn't mad at it
i didn't believe what i now believe
which was that every day they were doing
that the world was getting worse as a
result of their doing it right that's
that took me a long time to get to
but maybe the origin moment for me there
was the moment you just described
where it occurred to me and i think this
is very important for those of us who
have a critique of inequality of a
critique of oligarchy of how america
works today
you have to understand the banality
um through which it is prosecuted it is
prosecuted
in a million different ways some of
which are
involve hard power and kind of
structural violence and
lobbying and all kinds of but but a lot
of which
involve the infiltration and conquest of
the culture and one little moment that
exemplifies that is sitting in a room at
the aspen institute
all these business people but also
non-business people there were students
in that room there are all kinds of
people in that room
yes sitting there receiving a
presentation
sponsored by goldman sachs i was told
goldman sachs paid hundreds of thousands
of dollars
to advertise to us a few hundred of us
in that lunch and no mention being made
a few years after it helped cause the
financial crisis of
any of its complicity in that and
instead this notion
of goldman sachs championing 10 000
small businesses for women owned by
women
and so i got up and raised my hand and
said you know it's great that goldman's
giving these women
advice but based on what i'm hearing
about these actually wonderful women on
stage small business owners
it may be better for them to give
goldman sachs advice
about how to run businesses in the
honorable ethical way that they seem to
be much more knowledgeable
about and you're right it was the origin
point because it felt like
what was happening there is what i later
came to call the aspen consensus which
is fundamentally the notion
you know the phrase the washington
consensus there's now talk of a beijing
consensus
i tried to coin this notion of an aspen
consensus which defines
hyper capitalism in our age in america
which is
ask the richest most powerful people the
winners of our age
to do more good to help out to give back
to chip in
but never ask them to do less harm
never ask them to stop uh you know
dumping externalities into the society
never ask them to stop causing climate
change never ask them to stop making
kids
get diabetes with their sugary drinks
never ask them to
stop lobbying for bottle service public
policy that's good for them bad for most
people
never ask them to start paying their
proper taxes
just tell them to exploit the system and
the continued ways that they
continue exploiting the ways that they
have been and then
donate some of the table scraps to a
fraction of those they've spent their
lives hurting
i was privy to
uh a lot of what you're you're
describing where if someone makes a ton
of money and one of the things i love
about your critique is like
just about all of our major media
platforms will occasionally have some
story about
like billionaire x says this billionaire
x believes that
uh and you never questions like why do i
give a [ __ ] what billionaire
excess or cares about it's like like
did did that be next to his name somehow
uh make him like the most learned person
in
in the land like that did this it's the
famous phb degree
yeah he got the php degree which trumps
all you know uh
where um that the critique
because you see it everywhere uh where
there is this
market-based thinking that has grown to
just predominate our every waking moment
and it's even worse now because a lot of
the things that used to be uncountable
are now accountable
it's like it used to be like hey how
good a person are you well let me
see what your social media says
but i think that the notion you point to
is really important to just pause on for
a second
this id because part of what i try to do
in winners take all is is broaden
the explanation of an age of inequality
and so there's a lot of the stuff we
normally focus on like what are the tax
rates
very important what's the lobbying
that's going on what's the role of money
in politics that's allowable all these
things incredibly important
and are a huge part of the story of how
we the scaffolding
um of an age of inequality however
there's a bunch of other supports
of an age of inequality that are less
talked about and so you name one that's
really important that people don't think
about a lot
which is the turning
of rich people into thinkers
this is not a naturally occurring
phenomenon like rainfall
this is an engineered occurrence right
like
the notion that someone like steven
schwartzman or
ray dalio or mark zuckerberg
is a person whose thoughts
we should think about at a higher
proportion than they're allowed to
express them through a vote
is laughable on its face i mean not only
these people not more important
as thinkers than you know a lot of
people
they're often quite dumb as thinkers
relative to the average person because
they're so
you know parched for actual information
about how people live in the society
and yet there's this process by which
these billionaires become thinkers they
become what i call thought leaders in
the book right and they
and they turn into these figures and
what's so brilliant about it andrew
is that if there was just like a
billionaire in a velvet robe
smoking a cigar drinking you know
corvoisier and
and said you know andrew yang you're
running for president i have some
thoughts
about tax policy you'd be like get the
[ __ ] away from me
okay but now if that person wait
are you saying like for real because we
all know politicians actually listen
very long and hard to what that person
i'm talking about but i'm talking about
correct now i'm talking about you i'm
talking about you
like i think you are more alive to that
threat
than a lot of people out there maybe i'm
wrong but i think you are right
if that person just was like nakedly
like
i'm trying to get rich i'm trying to
keep my wealth i would like to talk to
you
about tax policy i think you'd be
squeezing well
or you could be like i have a pretty
good sense of what you're about to say
correct you'd be well defended let's put
it that way
if you wanted to be now if that same
person
barnacles a couple things onto
themselves right let's say they suddenly
get really involved
with helping girls in africa by the way
someone once said to me i was reporting
the book
there's a reason all these guys love
investing in girls right they love girls
as soon as girls become women
they don't like treating them
particularly well but they they love
investing in them when they're still
girls
so he does some girls stuff in africa
right never been to africa but he does
some girl stuff there
he's donating to public schools in
gary indiana you know uh andy's got a
book out
about three solutions to the economic
challenge of the united states same
billionaire
same naked interest now that guy comes
to you
is he gonna say i'm concerned about
losing my wealth no
he's gonna say andrew yang you talk
about you know this massive churn in our
society this future of automation all
these things i want to talk to you about
gary indiana where i'm very involved in
the school system
well how are you going to turn that
meeting down he now has a platform
to talk to you and then
and i'm not saying it's about you
specifically but once he's having that
conversation once he's in relationship
with you on the basis of that much
gentler approach
that doesn't leave you well defended at
some point one day you are going to get
a call
about the wealth tax issue or about the
capital gains thing right
and so what philanthropy and do-gooding
and all this stuff that i call the
charade
does for a lot of these folks is provide
them
a halo that actually allows them
to appear to be sages
on the question of the good society when
in fact
they are the reason among the principal
reasons
the society is sort of avoided um
the possibilities of being more good
a couple things i will stipulate that i
completely agree with you on i agree
with just about everything you just said
but one
one thing is that there is no way we
will ever get to a point we want to be
if the plan is to have people who are
the ultra winners in our society
uh give us like a tiny smidgen of what
they made
uh like it's just a loser it's like a
massive loser and if you look at
a lot of the scale of the philanthropy
i'm always impressed when someone's
giving enough money where it actually
hurts them where it pains them
i ran a non-profit for a number of years
and you're raising money from some of
these people and what you realize is
that even if someone has a b next to
their name
um they're not trafficking in like
increments of like tens of millions for
their philanthropy
it's like if they've got to be next to
their name then like
it gets translated through this
organization and they have like
ten they tend to have a small arm you
have handlers and then maybe you can
like get like
like a five or six figure check uh and
then if you're in that
how do you think they became
billionaires yeah and if you're in that
situation too if you're the non-profit
leader you can't be like
like what's this
[Laughter]
instead you're like oh well you know i
never threw it back in their face andrew
yeah you're like well you know i
appreciate this
generosity and then you think okay let
me try to build this relationship maybe
like i can get another zero on this
check like the next time so there's
there's never any like oh this is
um you know uh ungenerous because
and and that's when you talk about like
the
perspective of a billionaire one of the
the ideas i started telling my team
about
uh was what i called the force field
which is like like
when you become mega wealthy you end up
with like a force field around you and
the force field can be
com composed of people because you have
all like the small likes of people
around you that are like trying to
bat people away people like like me
who's you know running a nonprofit is
pretty predictable just like they were
concerned about tax policy for uh their
riches like if i'm the head of a
nonprofit you know i'm gonna ask you for
money at some point
so like um so they they have like the
force field around them
um and when you had a human exchange
with someone
who is like that where you felt like oh
like i felt like that actually kind of
uh pierced the force field like you
actually knew it because it was so rare
like it was a real rarity
but we'll never get to where we want to
go if the plan is for
us to somehow have some of these scraps
fall down on people
particularly because it's seldom the
case the scraps are actually significant
in relation to the person's
wealth yeah but but i would i would have
two reactions to that yeah
i think what in a way what you're
talking about is
i think there are two different kinds of
miserliness
that we are talking about here right and
what you just laid out is the first and
most obvious kind as someone who had to
fundraise that was the kind that was
rubbed in your face
most often which is the which is
quantitative miserliness right which is
just like
they have x and the most they're ever
going to give you is point zero one
x okay that's like basic my the basic
miserliness of this
of this space right i think part of
where i have tried to take this argument
is even if we were to stipulate
something that is not true but
let's imagine everybody behave like bill
gates it still does not work out right
it still doesn't even if everybody had x
and everybody committed to giving 0.9 x
right and and guys like you when you
were running non-profits were
rolling in that money and and left even
so
the second kind of miserliness is these
folks
refuse whether or not they're willing to
part with their money they refuse to
part with their system
and that's where a bill gates is not
fundamentally different from
some of the people who are like jeff
bezos who are giving very little right
if you look at bezos and gates on
paper in terms of the first kind of
miserliness quantitative miserliness
they're very different
right bill gates is not quantitatively
miserly he's committed to give
you know genuinely philanthropic and
yeah i visited the gates foundation in
seattle have you visited that
that uh i have not i'm not invited to a
lot of places i
i went when i was doing passing the hat
for my non-profit like i'd go anywhere
so i ended up i i ended up getting a big
nothing but anyway i did get to visit
and it was the most beautiful
environment and campus and
office and had like a big message um
from from bill and melinda
and it was uh it was uplifting in the
sense that it was very well done
like you visited and you were like wow
this is uh the most impressive
um structure institution
and people were great too you know
they're they're a lot of the same sort
of people that you and i
um i've gone to school with or you know
are working in that space
um so yeah that's a shrine of giving but
it's also a shrine of taking too much
which is why it's so beautiful
it it's it's a shrine to something i
mean it was beautiful uh so i just
wanted to
just impart that experience to you that
uh that yeah like their philanthropy is
very
impressive in scale so so even if we say
like bill gates and bezos
on on miserliness number one are very
different right quantitative miserliness
they're different
gates gives a lot bezos is given quite a
little bit so far
um on miserly's number miserliness
number two
which is i would say qualitative
miserliness which is sort of
are you willing to part with the system
the set of assumptions the privileges
the impunity the immunity that has
defined
your time on the planet and this
amassing of fortune
then a bezos and a gates don't start to
look that different because when it
comes to
as you know well from from living inside
the process in many different ways
if if bill gates said
i want a universal basic income your
idea to happen
uh if bill gates wanted bernie and
elizabeth's
wealth tax to happen any of pic pick
would
whatever one of those kind of notions
major pillars or policies for five
billion dollars
you could probably get something like
that done right you could change a big
philanthropic initial
do what the kochs did but for good you
know buy some institutes
put ideas out in the culture sponsor
writers and thinkers the left's version
of charles murray who are
churning out these ideas get it done you
could do that the fact that
they're no billionaire this may sound
like an obvious statement but let's
state it the fact that no billionaire
that i know of has bankrolled billions
of dollars
toward advocating for a wealth tax tells
you
that on the question of the second
miserliness it is almost universal
regardless of how much money people are
willing to part with
now one of the most singular exceptions
i've seen and this is very recent
and i could definitely be biased against
this be biased because i'm one of the
recipients
um was jack dorsey's recent announcement
of a billion dollars because he's giving
straight to
mayors for guaranteed income uh
he's give he gave us five million
dollars that we immediately just
turned around and gave to uh people who
are struggling right now
so it was a great feeling people were
thanking us and i was just like honestly
i was like you know
i'm just like a conduit for um for some
of jack's wealth and there's a
significant proportion of his
net worth uh but i agree with you that
and you even qualified it you said that
like in virtually every case um like
this is not
the way they're heading i agree with you
because when you look at it most of them
are kind of taking for granted
certain structures that have facilitated
their
uh success and wealth and they have very
little interest in actually examining
those structures or
altering the way they work uh they look
around and you
point this out in your book is there
they look around and say okay how can i
make you more successful
in the world as it is right now where
people like me become fantabulously
wealthy it's like how can i make you
more successful
in market world uh teach you a little
bit of the market magic
yes it's it's you know how can i find
you
um a more comfortable nook in my dungeon
right there there's like you still gotta
live in my dungeon
and i still gotta live in this castle
but it would but it would be moving to
me
if i could donate some of my enormous
spoils
to finding you a more comfortable nook
in the dungeon
you know and so when it comes to jack to
pick apart a couple things there
here's what i think is impressive about
jack which is
i think jack has grappled with the
questions you and i are talking about
i know he read my book i know he read i
think a lot of other things
in this space there was a big piece in
recode about this recently
talking about his grappling i think jack
has
is one of the first mega givers
on the other side of the recent wave of
prominent critiques of big philanthropy
that doesn't mean
i endorse any or any everything he does
but but but there's you know as you know
there's just a power in like
grappling with questions as opposed to
ignoring them or swatting them off i
think he's grappled with them
and so some of the direct giving i think
reflects that some of the no strings
attached
i think grows out of a sense of not
wanting to rich splain
to ngos how they operate so there's i
see evidence
just a tiny note too for jack which i
found very impressive
he does not have an army of people
advising on his philanthropy that way
it's one of the reasons we put up the
google doc he was like look we're just
gonna
let folks know who we're giving it to
and i don't have like some army anyway
which is also unusual i i think where
i'm more troubled by jack
um is this notion
that is also at the heart of the book
which is that there has there is this
notion now
that virtue is a side hustle right and
that it is acceptable
for your day job to be done in a way
that contributes to social problems and
then you have the side hustle
of virtue and so when i look at jack i
look at someone whose twitter platform
which i spend a lot of time on you spend
time on
has real problems that people have
pointed out
and the solution of which would in many
cases mean
less profitability uh for twitter right
you could you can hire
more monitors to fared out neo-nazi
content i mean it's just a
it's just the number of people if if the
number you have isn't working you can
hire more
but that's money uh you know if
you actually had everybody have to have
a driver's license to be on twitter or
some kind of identity so you don't have
random trolls and russian bots whatever
that would probably crimp their growth
quite a bit
right and so when i look at someone like
jack i said
the real power you have over america
five million dollars is sort of a lot of
money but it's not actually a lot of
money
like the real power jack has over
american life
is platforming or deep platforming the
president
like allowing white supremacy to have
a online viral presence
or not um allowing twitter to be a place
that
many women fundamentally and foremost
experience as a place of abuse
or not these are all solvable problems
they just cost money and they crimp
profitability
and i personally and people may disagree
with me on this
i would be fine with jack
solving the problems in his own house
making less money as a result
and having less to give to you to give
to others that
you know that that we have to be honest
about the consequence
of reducing these opportunities
for the winners to exploit us exploit
our society means they will have less to
give away
but as someone i was doing an event in
london with
uh the economist of all of all places it
was a tense
tense moment um and this woman stood up
after i'd been talking about his litany
of social problems the united states
this woman stood up in london she's like
i'm from i think she's from sweden or
norway
i feel very you know guilty confusing
those peoples but she was from one of
them i'm sure
you're hurting someone's feeling i am
right now i'm gonna get cancelled for
this
scandy canceled um and she said
you know i'm from scandinavia and
you know i want to say we don't have
um as many billionaires as you do in the
united states and we don't have this
much giving that you have the united
states
but i gotta tell you i listen to your
entire litany of social problems
and we don't have most of those either
so i would kind of take that deal if
only i could remember which country it
was
your fundamental argument that if we had
better rules of the road
that would probably mint fewer
billionaires but would also throw out
many fewer negative externalities
in every which way environmental social
economic cultural
i agree with it fundamentally that the
problem that we have
is that those rules of the road would
theoretically be set by government
and our government has been completely
overrun by market world thinking
has been captive completely ignorant on
technology issues like have
essentially just been sitting there
clapping and being like you know
like we don't understand you but we
sense that you're
uh very rich
so like maybe you could uh i mean
literally as we're having this
conversation i mean i think our country
is having a
re-examination certainly of tech's
uh negative impacts but you don't need
to
focus just on tech even though tech
might be one of the biggest examples
given our
legislators complete ignorance about
technology issues
i mean you can look at even some of the
older industries and think like hey are
there now excesses
that are allowing i mean the biggest one
is clearly finance i mean that thing is
like
bananas where it's become the tail
wagging the dog
in our economy it used to be that
financiers were essentially just
uh helpers to industry uh
and and i thought of ge essentially as
the
emblem of this where my dad worked for
ge uh he immigrated
you know here about my mom and at
berkeley and then became
an engineer in schenectady where i was
born in new york
and that was when ge was making things
and inventing things
and then ge kind of morphed with the
economy
into ge credit had this like giant
financial institution at one point i
think they were one of like the top 10
lenders in the country and then they
blew up with a financial crisis
and so what happened with ge uh
it really was an emblem of american
business because it went from building
things to all of a sudden just
you know moving numbers around uh and
the rewards for people at the top of the
finance industry have
zero relationship with the amount of
good that's being done or social benefit
and that became egregiously clear to all
of us when
the economy blew up in 08 where you
looked around you you had the sense it's
like hey
like i feel like there are some excesses
here but at least
it seems to be creating value and then
it turns out it's like no it was not
creating any value at all it was
actually just
um putting people into homes and trying
to
that that weren't appropriate and then
preying on people who are vulnerable
and then trying to paper it all over by
smushing them into these
uh uh mortgage-backed securities and
collateralized debt obligations that no
one could understand and that was really
their business was just making [ __ ] that
no one understood until it was too late
uh so the question is
really like we're at a point where now
we've experienced decades of excesses
and if you could have done it right you
would have a time machine and say like
hey some of these industries are going
to end up growing in ways that
are bad for everyone it's going to mint
fantastically wealthy people far in
excess of
anything that any human probably quote
unquote deserves
um and it is very painful when someone
who becomes incredibly wealthy is like
oh i worked hard it's like well
you know so did that cleaning person and
they're not a billionaire you know
like like your your hard work has it
really somehow
um you know made you worth like you know
100 000 times
like the person who teaches my kids but
uh but we don't have the time machine
we're here we're in 2020 where it's like
you know the excesses have grown to like
mammoth proportions
you're one of the people that i think
has pointed out the ridiculousness and
hypocrisy of like a lot of these
situations
and how deeply brainwashed we've all
become
that market-based thinking is the only
thinking
and if the post office doesn't make
money then [ __ ] the post office
if you know like if if local newspapers
don't make money [ __ ] local newspaper is
it like
pretty much any anything you look around
and say like what it it's not
paying for itself then like you turn on
it train lines whatever the heck they
are
uh so we're here you're one of the
foremost leaders saying like hey guys
like we've lost the thread um and
attacking people for not being
market world successful is ridiculous
like we need a whole different
approach intellectually i
agree and i ran on this platform that's
like hey let's try and disentangle
human value and economic value and the
single most dramatic way to do so i
believe is just
universal based income let's just start
giving people money and oh by the way
it's
necessary because we're going to get rid
of a lot of the most common jobs in
american life anyway because of
technology which is then gotten
accelerated by the pandemic so i agree
with your diagnosis
i agree with your critique of the
various players
i look around and you and i traffic and
i'd love to hear about like whether
you're now cast out of the circles
because i just imagine i was about to
say you and i travel in the same circles
now i'm not so sure
[Laughter]
i don't know if you've been
excommunicated yeah i've lost some
circles and gained some new ones
the new ones are better than the old
ones i would love to hear about
that because that is fascinating and
that's been true of every
important thing i've ever done where
i've like lost some circles and gained
some
truth through my presidential race too
uh
so here we are um and i had this this
set of policy proposals that i thought
would at least start to improve
people's lives in a way and start to
disentangle this thinking
um i mean actual
modern regulation of technology in other
industries has to be a piece of the
puzzle or pillar in this structure
the thing that i find frustrating when i
talk to people about it is like
they still cast back on what i regard as
relatively
backward looking approaches or solutions
where it's like let's say we were to
like gin up the
income tax to something more progressive
which i completely agree with
and i'll even say go a step further we
also start treating capital gains the
same way we do labor income which
is at a minimum what we should do right
capital gains if anything should be
taxed higher
uh like so if if people argue for those
solutions
like to me like that horse is already
out of the barn you know what i mean
like the like a lot of the wealth has
already been generated correct and one
of the the things i say to someone
is like look let's say i made income
taxes
seventy percent uh you know how much is
jeff bezos gonna pay
and then they think about it and they're
like i don't know i was like do you
think we're gonna get like
billions of dollars from jeff based on
my changing income tax
uh and then they they say
no and i'm like yeah because he's not an
idiot he's not going to pay himself 10
billion a year
you know he pays himself something
manageable and most of his
stocks getting most of his wealth is an
amazon stock uh
and how much did amazon pay in tax last
year zero it's like all right so
you know like he's way too clever for
like higher income taxes to somehow
do the trick so let me i mean so
first couple things you know i think
when i
first of all i want to say this on the
universal basic income i i
i said this in a tweet before and i i'll
i'll say it to your face now like i
when the pandemic struck um
i quite immediately began to feel like
your ubi advocacy
took on an obviousness
that had eluded me during the campaign
right um and i'll get to why in a second
like i
i feel like you were singing a song that
became very obvious to a lot of people
once you suddenly have millions of
people
from one week to the next thrown out in
the street
um losing jobs being evicted you know
it's been obvious to me and many other
people for a while you shouldn't tie
health care
to employment for example right and i
think the point you were making was that
you shouldn't tie
employment to the rudiments of
you know human dignity living and
but particularly you know i i i have
this quote in the book from a from a guy
at a
at a platform cooperativism which is
this movement
uh event and you know he says in every
age
there are certain things that people
don't have a choice
but to use right like you don't choose
the world
and and one and those things should not
be expensive right so the internet is a
good example of that like it's not a me
you don't have a choice to not use the
internet
right like your kids are gonna have
assignments on it like that's that's not
a choice so that should not be
that should be free and and to broaden
that a little bit
it used to be granaries in a different
era right um and
to broaden it i think one way to think
about one way to say what you
have said very eloquently on this is you
know
if costs are a certain thing
because we have monopolies because we
have lack of
like if costs are what they are if this
is then
there's a certain minimum existence
people need to have that is not there
it's not their fault that the rents are
what
you know what they are it's not so so i
i
you know i was very persuaded by that i
was belatedly persuaded by it because of
the pandemic and i think you deserve a
lot of credit
for for elevating that i'll tell you
what my lingering
non-pandemic reservation is and i'm
curious your thought then we can go to
the rest of the
here we are now agenda um my reservation
is and i think i mentioned this in the
book that it
i fear that a ubi assumes
a bleak future for ordinary people in a
way
that maybe uh
we can avoid yes yes
i fear that it concedes a point that i'm
not willing to concede
which is you know for example 40 percent
of people will not have regular work
whatever the numbers are right
like yeah i'm and you're more of an
expert on these actual trends than i am
for sure
but i view any of those types of
outcomes
as being the product of politics not the
product of forces like i actually don't
think
like i think there is some tax regime
some regulatory regime in place
where even profound technological shifts
do not have those impacts now i don't
know if they're passable i don't know if
we're gonna do them
but part of i think part of why and i
know you come at it from a very
different place but part of why the ubi
is very popular in the valley
right and a lot of those people love you
more than you love them back
is because i think what they hear in
your ubi thing
is like we'll get to continue
the current power relations of the
country like
we'll get to continue having these
monopolies
we'll get to continue having labor
procarity
so that we don't have to make uber
drivers work like and now
in a way i just worry that the
well-meaning thing
becomes almost an excuse to not change
those power equations we don't need to
fix labor law
to fight this notion of people being
made contractors instead of employees
because they'll have a ubi we don't need
to rebuild unions
because even if we don't people will be
eating and living um
and i'm not sure where i land on it to
be honest um which is i think something
you're not supposed to say but like i
don't know what i think about this you
know
but i'm curious how you think about
the risk of conceding a
future that's bad for workers when in
fact we may have democratic choices we
could make that would make the future
not unfold like that at all
i don't think i was arguing for the
future anymore
like i just looked outside my window and
said this is here and now
this is where we are if you look around
is the precarity already here
like are americans working two or three
jobs uh
you know do school teachers have to
commute 90 minutes
in order to like you know come teach
people's kids in rich areas and then
have uber
advertise to them that like hey we found
school teachers make good uber drivers
and parentheses we know that you can't
live just on the school teacher salary
anymore
i mean all of like the bleak [ __ ] that
people fear
is here uh now the pandemic sped it up
um and made it crystal clear um
but all you have to do is look at our
legislators and say like hey have these
people been on the ball
like making the right political choices
for the last x number of years so
a lot of it on is this like like i i
just said look
[ __ ] is much bleaker and nastier right
now than most people
accept uh and as soon as you actually
scratch the surface and flip the rock
over you're like whoa
like this is actually really really dark
and punishing and inhuman and destroying
people
people's ways of life are disintegrating
right and left i spent i mean you were
from
you grew up in the midwest right for at
least a period yeah
yeah like i mean i've spent always
telling you to go back to my country and
it's like you know i'm not going back to
cleveland
yeah shaker heights i have some friends
from there so
i saw what happened to ohio you know
like the aftermath
of the decimation of manufacturing jobs
has just left a lot of those communities
in a really rough spot
it was a woman in cleveland who said to
me she said hey around here changes the
four letter word
and i had to figure out what the heck
she was talking about i was like
it's factually not but also how can you
regard change as so negative
and was only after spending time with
her she said look for us change means
the plant closing people leaving
success here in this part of ohio means
leaving
it's one reason why lebron coming back
was such a big deal is that like if you
just see people deserting your
town right and left then if i say hey
we're going to change things around here
like your mind immediately goes to well
like
that's probably bad for me because any
because like i haven't seen a good
change in quite some time
so but what do you think about this
notion of i mean
what the people you're talking about
lack is both money
and power right um
by which i mean political power in
particular right so if you're that
union you know union or ex-union
personnel in ohio sure right a you have
less money because of the
industrialization
but b like you may not have a union job
anymore
or your union maybe have less membership
maybe less powerful
may have less pull all true now
my concern would be but but talk me out
of it like
my concern would be okay we start giving
that person
12 000 a year as a guaranteed income
great does that
i'm concerned that that doesn't fix the
power issue and that there's other
problems in their life
i'm going to pitch those schools and
this and that that will not
just be fixed by them having more cash
in it but there's some issues that will
be
but their lack of power will still
result in and that and that it might
reduce the urgency
of dealing with what feels like the
fundamental issue
this is really important to me so number
one i'm not
against uh other things that help
improve that person's situation
you know i'm for giving them money and
i'm for easing uh
you know the ability for people to to
form unions and collectively bargain
like i'm for ways to pay teachers more
like to me like you can be for all these
things because they're all the right
things to do
but here's the bigger thing is that
community
more empowered to actually be able to
stand in line and vote
to actually resist employer exploitation
to actually
like maybe make some investments in
their schools or volunteer their time
for their kids at the pta or like
whatnot that's right
if they have that money in their pocket
so you're also going to hate me
to be civic you're get you're giving
them the kind of space in their life to
be civic
yes like right now you know if you say
to someone who like and i've been to
these
you have to i'm sure like you're with
this person ohio you're like hey get out
and vote
like they look at you and they're
they're like this does not [ __ ]
matter to me at all like my vote does
not matter
uh and they have in many cases like
decades of experience telling them just
that
you know and then there are people that
like will never come near it
um because uh
they're completely in despair or you
know like like
they're completely disconnected from
civic society um
and that to me is not uh extraordinary
anymore
and it's not even irrational that's the
toughest part anna you can't be like hey
if you just get your ass and vote we're
going to fix everything it's like
actually not really like they could come
and vote and like
you know their person just gets co-opted
or their person just one vote and
like a chorus or their person like it's
um
like the power dynamics are so broken um
and then
selling to them that like hey this
vote's gonna do it for you if you just
get that person into city council or
school board
it's like you know that's not true like
you know that these systems when the
person gets there
like even if they're good they're gonna
get like their hands cuffed and like
gonna be hold behold into some [ __ ]
and then
they'll be out voted by like you know
that they're like you know crazy
uh cohort on the city council or school
board or state legislature or u.s
congress or whatever it happens to be
uh the the the restoration of their
ability to make better choices
is contingent upon them actually having
like the means to
survive and be able to decide what to do
with six hours of their time
like it's ridiculous right now to go to
someone who's like destitute and like
struggling and can't make ends meet
you know what i want you to do now i
want you to volunteer i want you to vote
i want you to spend this time
it's like like like a lot more and more
americans are responding with a big [ __ ]
you
like it you know and so like to me the
big step
if you get money in those people's hands
it gets their head up
and to use an international reference
that people know it's like
if you look at countries that have more
robust social benefits
like civic engagement goes up protests
go up like you know like various things
happen where if you have some degree of
liberty
then it's not a sedative it's a sale to
the right
give people free money and then they'll
protest more you know
well i'm just saying it's like give give
people money and they'll have actual
like energy
and visibility and the ability to
participate i'm i'm convinced by that i
think part of where i had the
you know before you were selling it the
people i most heard in interval
particularly i was reporting the book
selling this
were like silicon valley venture
capitalists whose reasons are very
different from yours who didn't say any
of the things you just said
and and if i had to summarize what i
heard from a lot of them
it was essentially let's bribe people
not to revolt
right the future is going to be bad for
these people we want a future
in which tech will be left alone won't
be regulated and which monopoly will be
able to function with impunity which
there will be wealth taxes there won't
be
higher taxes on capital gains and and
high incomes we want that future
and so let's conceive this i'm just
talking about from their point of view
like what is a way that we can get on
board
with an efficiently distributed social
program
that will be insurance they're kind of
like
libertarian insurance and like and
protect our ability to keep being us and
i know you come at it from a very
different place
but that's that was the intersection
that that always worried me but but
i but i but i hear what you're saying
and i think i'm not sure maybe i didn't
hear it i'm not sure i heard you talk
about this in the
in the campaign as much which is like
this notion of
if you expect people to be civic you
need to
you need to like buy space you need to
show you
you actually give a [ __ ] about them
because like right now we're just paying
lip service it's like hey great news
you're an american you can vote
it's like we're not going to invest in
you your neighborhood your family or
schools in any way
and if we do invest in them we're going
to make it ridiculously paternalistic
and like bludgeon the [ __ ] out of you
and just make you feel like
a less than human being at every step of
the way
um but we love you and value and care
about it like the whole thing
you know one of the things that i
compare it to and it's like when you
show up to a company you know
within like a day whether that company
gives a [ __ ] about you you know
i mean like that like that there's like
they're companies where they
and then even when they do invest and do
all the right things some of it's
misplaced and dumb
but you can at least tell like okay
they're kind of trying it's like like
this culture
means they have to at least show that
they're
investing something in their people um
in terms of like the citizenship
experience right now there are many
people that do not feel
genuinely that we are investing in them
and they're not wrong
like that this would be the biggest
reversal of that one of the things i
campaigned on was saying
uh you know imagine a country where you
could look your kids in the eye and say
your country loves you your country
values you and your country will invest
in you and your future
like i mean does that kid actually take
civic engagement and voting much more
seriously
you know i think so and you know it's
like it because then the government
would be doing something concrete for
them that they could understand and
you know and it's very hard to argue
with it's one of the reasons why i ran
on it was like look
like it's hard to demonize cash
like it's hard to look at and say this
cash is going to hurt you
like it's it's one way that we can get
this thing done
and then make the changes like i think
it supercharges our ability to make the
other changes because it ends up
activating people
and activates folks who can then
start rolling back some of the things
that you're describing
a lot of people listening to yang speaks
are entrepreneurs
and run businesses and right now every
small business has to do more with less
uh a lot of folks are having a lot of
dynamism and like your
you know ability to find people like
maybe some folks like uh
can't work well one way you can find
workers
really quickly and reliably is
indeed.com it's the number one website
in the world
for finding folks fast we used it on the
campaign
and it works it's one of those things
where you know in some of these markets
uh like that there becomes like a
clearinghouse that
folks know on both sides it's like
employers know it
workers know it and that's what
indeed.com really has become
where you have 73 of online job seekers
visiting indeed every month so if you're
looking for someone they're more likely
to be on indeed it's just the way this
stuff
works and right now indeed is offering
our listeners a free 75
credit to boost your job post which
means more
candidates will see it so try indeed out
with a free 75
credit at indeed.com yang this is the
best offer
available anywhere go right now to
indeed.com
yang this offer is valid through
september 30th and terms and conditions
[Music]
apply
so i'm curiou like you know you were
saying
there has been this war the war on
normal people as you call it for
for decades um but we are it is what it
is now we are
where we are and the question is what
are the remedies now
and you know so i advocate for things
like
uh wealth tax you know i i would by the
way your
your um your comrades bernie and
elizabeth i actually think their wealth
taxes
didn't go far enough uh you know not
even bernie's
you know would have slowed the rate of
billionaires getting richer it would
have smoothed the derivative of the
derivative right
yeah i i understand of course you would
say that um that's why you got the hat
so you know this
this notion of an erosive wealth tax i
think is something we should be talking
about you know some of the things you
mentioned capital gains
uh higher tax on extreme incomes aoc
talked about going back to 70
on 10 million or more those kinds of
things but i have a more basic question
um or thing i'd like to run by you and
since you were in this system
which is it seems to me one of the big
frustrations for me
is that when it comes to these kinds of
transformational
changes which whether it's the one
you're talking about the ones i'm
talking about
i to put it very simply have a feeling a
fear
the democrats don't know how to talk
right
that republican if you think about what
republicans do they take
policies that are bad for most people
that actually make that war on normal
people
they take those policies and then they
package them really popular they package
them so well
and it's like it's like sports right
it's like it's like when you're
practicing for a sport you actually try
challenges that are way harder than the
actual sport like you keep shooting
hoops from
you know half court and then like maybe
you'll be able to make a three-pointer
in the actual game like i feel the
republicans have set themselves up for
this amazing athletic
challenge which is we are committed to
policies that
you know only benefit the one percent
and so our athleticism
as republicans in marketing
selling those tickling the reptile brain
using language getting into people's
heads appealing to their aspirations
their hopes
their fears i feel their game is on
point right because for them to win they
literally have to
multiply by 51 times
a 51 multiple the number of people who
support a policy you know for
the number of people who a positive
benefit to the number of people who
support it right
and that athleticism that results from
that challenge is amazing
it's awful but it's amazing and i
to continue this metaphor i feel like
democrats are often in this position
whether it's health care whatever the
specific proposals
where there's almost this like kind of
intellectual
flabbiness that sets in where like
you got policies that would clearly
benefit 99
most people or 65 of people or 70
of people almost every major policy
we're talking about here
right many of them in the 90s maybe some
we could be more modest and say
70 to 80 of people and i almost feel
there's this
laziness or lack of athleticism that's
set in
where democrats are unable to take
things that would make
90 of people's lives better and sell
them to 51 of people
whereas republicans are able to take
things that make one percent of people's
lives
better than some than 51 percent of
people and to me a lot of it is someone
who thinks about languages who's
my only real you know craft is language
output is language um i think a lot
about how incapable democrat the
democratic party
not all democrats but the democratic
party as an institution and many
democrats
are when it comes to to
tickling the reptile brain giving people
simple ideas they can understand
not talking about block grants i wonder
what your experience of that is being
inside the machinery
you have hit on a very very powerful
prob a powerful idea and a very big
problem and it's something that you and
i need to help democrats with
uh so here's the deal i show up i'm
running for president you know
i'm like an entrepreneur i think in a
certain way i talk in a certain way
and it turns out that the language i'm
using is not the political language that
i'm supposed to be using it
at all and it's like oh
this is the way i think you'd talk um
and and so
what happened to me and this is an
example of why
you know for example like when you like
saw my arguing for universal basic
income like you weren't sold
is that what i belatedly realized anand
is that like
my natural means of delivering
these ideas or arguing for them like
actually just was like a different
variety of symbol
like a different variety of appeal it's
a it's almost like the no appeal
is like it's like its own appeal
and then you had folks who'd been in the
game for a long time
who were incredibly fluent
in like their versions of political
language and there's this giant class of
folks you're probably friends with some
of them
um that are like dc consultants who are
saying it's like hey
argue it this way argue it this way and
it will inflame this particular
group and so you end up with these uh
speeches that end up just becoming
essentially like a check the box being
like i'm now going to say this and it's
going to excite
women i'm going to say this and it's
going to excite people who care about
climate change i'm going to say this and
it's like
and then you have the rights version of
the same things
it's like you know we're going to appeal
to loyalty
and patriotism and order
and uh like hierarchy
and nostalgia or like whatever the heck
the the package of things is
um and what you're saying right now is
so important
is like that their package of appeals is
more potent
than democrats to more
human beings who reside in this country
also
known as voters and this is a very
dangerous thing
and then you go to the folks who are
arguing for some of the policies that
you and i are discussing which i
completely advocate for and agree with
and they're arguing for it in language
that's never going to rise past a
certain level of support
it's like they're going to get like a
very hardcore uh
they're gonna get a hardcore whatever
the number is
34 percent 28 percent like 40 and and
then
and you know there's this growing group
of people that are like what the heck is
going on why can't we win
51 of people over and
and so what do we do like you know like
one thing is to say to folks
who are on a particular side arguing for
medicare for all or other things
um to be like look like maybe we need to
try and take lessons from
uh some of the appeals they're making um
that will and so one of the things i
said on the debate stage was like look
you know one of the best
sell for fixing health care in this
country is like right now it's terrible
for anyone who wants to start a business
switch jobs like anything different it's
like giant job lock
it's holding us all in place like if you
want
dynamism and small businesses to
flourish then we need to
get health care like away from jobs
now i i think that's a 100 accurate
and there are many many republicans who
are small business owners one of the
things that pains me the most on it
is that i love small business owners i
think small business owners are
like the life's blood of many uh
communities
and more small business owners are
republicans in part i think because
democrats are just like talking about it
wrong
right like it kills me because like i
just like just on that
like a couple things on that just on
that point so important so
like i think of republic if you if you
hired republican strategist to like help
democrats sell universal health care
right medicare for all let's say or
something like that
um i think you'd hear
to to weaponize what the insight you
just said right there's a million
reasons i mean the reason i actually
support medicare for all is not
the reason you just said it's one of
them but it's i
i'm more personally inclined to the
human rights nature of it having this
not be a thing that people worry about
you know but but as you say what you
just said is an
excellent target for republicans
right who like small business now to me
what a republican strategist would do
here would take your idea
and and they would call employer-based
healthcare that entire system which is
our system
call it donald trump small business tax
right i'm just giving you a you know
right yeah no they're great at naming
things right like like
donald trump's new business tax right
because anybody starting a new business
is effectively paying a tax by having to
lose their health care right
and suddenly you've now shifted the
dynamic
or you know you take the wealth tax
right and you call it the patriots like
some of this stuff is trivial and some
of it
goes deeper right but but look how well
the right did by
calling late term abortion partial birth
abortion like look how well they did by
calling the estate tax the death tax so
this kind of
language stuff first of all um
have you read jonathan hates uh uh
righteous mind right
yeah yeah anyway so he talks about that
they appeal to more
core values than uh than democrats do
republicans do like another argument
i've said this in speeches of mine i've
seen
like people in the room think in a way
that you know doesn't happen in an age
of polarization every day
they say you know we should say about
health care
we already got the people we've got the
issue is people we don't
have right and we have a sense of what
some of those people's values are
right they're not into health as a human
right that's not working
they're not into solidarity they don't
be like scandinavia okay
so you gotta you gotta first get that
you gotta meet them where they are you
gotta
understand that which i think democrats
often just don't wanna do
okay that person may like a certain
where in that person's worldview do they
like solidarity they don't like
solidarity where you're coming from
which is healthcare
but where do they actually like
solidarity you know they like it the
military
where do they really like it they like
it in like wars right
oh like band of brothers kind of thing
right so why don't why don't you hear
democrats saying
when we sent our boys to normandy
right they didn't leave one person down
on the battlefield if they could avoid
it right they didn't want some
new bride in indiana not to know what
happened to her husband
they ran back they put themselves in
danger they picked that's
that's what we do that's who we are as
americans
and when i'm president that's what we're
going to do on the battlefield of
healthcare
right just i'm making this up it doesn't
even actually make sense no
no it was genius it took you 10 seconds
to come up with it
and we need more people arguing along
those lines
appealing to different chords
and core values uh so the healthcare is
a human right which i agree with
um you know that's like the caring core
value
correct uh and and then the republicans
have core values around loyalty
and uh sacredness and order
um that democrats don't talk about as
much or don't talk about as effectively
by the way sacredness can say one thing
on sacredness another
like our current health care system
turns your employer
into god you want to talk to christians
like
you're in an employer-based healthcare
system your employer is
playing a role in your life that only
god should actually play which is
deciding whether you live or die
deciding whether you're healthy or sound
do you want your employer to be god that
that's not an appeal that's going to
work on me
but that might work on some christians
yes i think that democrats
completely abandoned well not completely
but largely abandoning
any faith-based value arguments uh
is not good you know it's like like you
can say like look i don't believe what
you believe but
it's like you know i mean like like this
is these are just different ways
and anna this is one of the most
fundamental lessons i got in learning
for president
was like i thought i was arguing for
things that like most people
you know like would regard as like quite
progressive um but because i was arguing
them from my own perspective uh
like i ended up having like a very
different
appeal um and it blew
my mind that the substance and the
messaging
were um
were formed by each other to that extent
you know like i i thought i'd end up
being like
the leftiest seeming guy in the world
because i'm literally just trying to get
rid of poverty and give everyone money
and i thought that would be like wow
even bernie didn't take it that far
but instead like i ended up being cast
in this
strange different realm um in part
because
of just who i am like i have a
particular approach in like different
like a particular way i argued things uh
and so i ended up attracting folks who
found that line of argumentation
appealing or like you know
like like facts and figures of a certain
way or
um i wanna and it was totally surprising
to me like you know like i did not
realize
that that that's how this worked um so
because now that i've learned that i
completely affirm what you're saying
which is that we need to start trying to
communicate for some of the same goals
two different people in different ways
that will actually speak to them
and and i and i think i would break that
problem
the blockages down into actually two
different blockages which is a skill
issue and a will issue so what you and i
have been talking about
right now until now is sort of the skill
issue here like
democrats don't know how to do this
often and don't know how to do the
packaging genuinely
right do not but there's a will issue
which has to be talked about also
which is i think the democratic party
as a constellation is
a victim of its own like high-mindedness
its own sense of moral purpose its own
like very high levels of educational
attainment um
i mean you look at the education of
everybody who was running you and
everybody else
right and you know i think piketty at
this line a couple years ago like
about you know the democrats becoming
the harvard party or
you know the kind of brahmin party and
it's not what you want it's not what you
want
and i think what's come with that is a
kind of
however you say that they mark marquis
of queensberry rules
about playing nice and playing noble and
going you know
i i am not sure michelle obama is
correct about going high when they go
low
i i i i i think it depends on how
they're going low and what the outcomes
are
you know and and so so when i think
about
and i actually you achieved this with
ubi i think if you and i were walking
down the street
in kentucky right now i think people
would stop you and know your one
idea they may not know anything else you
said but i think a lot of people walking
down the street in kentucky would
recognize you
and recognize that one idea which i'm
not sure they'd be able to do for joe
biden
they'd recognize him i'm not sure they'd
be able to name one idea so i think your
ubi
achieved the status that i'm about to
describe which is if you look at the
wall
trump's wall obviously a [ __ ] dumb
idea
in terms of like should this idea be
achieved okay
but now let's put that aside and look at
it from a political analysis
lens right you had three big anxieties
in this country which were well
documented and trump was particularly
gifted at
sensing or his people were right
immigration
and more broadly a threat of a browning
country
terrorism which is again another kind of
threat from without
that could strike at any moment and
economic dislocation i'm not getting
enough
other people must be getting something
in one
single word idea that turned out to be
totally [ __ ] but in one single word
idea the man was able to communicate
something
that everybody remembers people will
remember 30 years from now
that actually tickled the reptile brain
on all three of those anxieties and it
made them feel like protected from the
world
now they were wrong he was wrong but
like it's an example
you talk about math it's an example of
like elegance
all right and i think you're the ubi
idea
whether you like it or not is you know
one of its hallmarks
is that it's a similar kind of elegance
anybody and there's a reason you
probably said it a thousand instead of
you know
1356. right like you want
but i think in general i mean elizabeth
warren said this before i interviewed
right before he went on stage in south
by southwest she's like
we've got to be the party that stopped
us using words like block grants
like who knows how to block grant even
it like and so
how do you think about that notion of
you know real policies are nuanced how
do you think about
balancing that imperative for nuance and
complexity and the fact that this is a
big country that needs
multifarious solutions how do you think
about balancing that with like
elegance and simplicity and giving
people something with
a wall like uh you know memorability
and emotive force
it's one reason why i did center the
campaign around idea that
the cleaning person in iowa would
recognize me for it say hey
like thousand bucks a month i'd be like
yes uh and
the painful part on and when you talk
about the fear that the democrats are
becoming like the bookworm party
or whatnot is like when i was in ohio or
iowa
talking to a waitress or a truck driver
they had a very very visceral negative
reaction to even the word democrat
it's like hey i'm running for president
oh like which party democrat like oh
like it it'd be like i like i just said
that i was like from like the
you know vermin party or like that like
and what do you think that was
because oh so i i think it's
both things i mean you know maybe they
watch a lot of fox news and have like
particular
ideas are presented to them about
democratic priorities but i think that
the democratic party really has lost its
ability to speak to working-class
concerns in a way that does not seem
somehow
patronizing condescending urban-centered
like something because
you know a lot of the environments i was
in were not big cities
and so the danger for democrats really
is that they become the
um the bookworm party the urban party
and then you lose more and more um folks
in uh small towns around the country
where they won't even listen to you
like it's and that was like a really
tough experience
because i always assumed the democrats
were for working-class people
like that trucker that waitress it's
like why would you be like so
uh disgusted with the democratic party
uh and uh that's one of the things that
i was hoping that we could try and steer
the party away from
which may or may not be happening now uh
but it's around to sort of simple appeal
what you're talking about
it's like like i'm not going to talk
about some other [ __ ] that might you
know like
end up frankly just like casting people
into different
cultural groups or tribes it's like i'm
gonna talk about a thousand bucks a
month like give it to everyone
and i'm genuinely more interested in
that too because i'm more interested in
those solutions rather than
like like who's going to win our totemic
struggle of the day
you know what it's like he's like who
cares really i mean the world's going to
[ __ ] like we can all see it like you
know how are we going to rebuild this
country
in a genuine effective way uh and so
this to me like a new foundation that
actually starts rejuvenating small
towns around the country which is what
you know putting this money into
people's hands
would do on many fronts but you're right
like if we could try and reframe
medicare for all in some way that that
was even simpler than that uh i'd be all
for it instead of build a wall we'd have
to think about
what the new big ideas are that would
universally translate you know i thought
of this so often during the campaign
um you had people advocating for
medicare for all and the progressive
going of the party and it occurred to me
as far as i know i could be wrong but as
far as i know
no one bothered to make a video
which would cost a couple thousand
dollars illustrating
what healthcare would look like
feel like be like how it would work to
get cared for
in the new world they proposed so you're
proposing medicare for all
i think it's the right idea i i also
think
unlike a lot of people advocate for it
that people who are scared of it
are not crazy or wrong it is a pretty
big shift
there would be mistakes there would be
glitches
some people actually may get into a
worse situation temporary like we got to
be real about that stuff but it's the
right thing
but when you are taking
insurance away from lots of people and
replacing it and doing this massive
societal transformation of you know a
massive sliver of the economy
helping people visualize it is something
that is so obvious to me right so why
wasn't there a video from bernie or
elizabeth anybody else
where you see someone getting sick scene
one
scene two they go to a clinic right they
get great care people are nice
scene three they're walking out they ask
you know it's new it's month
month two of the implementation they ask
where they should pay or their insurance
card and they're like
no courtesy of the united states of
america like
thank you so much for being a citizen
you know whatever right
that that would have just maybe helped
some people just and this is the kind of
thing i'm talking about where
not having an understanding of where
that waitress or truck driver
is psychologically what their fears are
what their anxiety
how they see not even having that
information available
because you're allowed you've allowed
yourself to become the harvard party
over time
is so profoundly dangerous and is so
wasteful
particularly when you have policies the
whole litany of policies
that would make all those people you're
talking about all their lives better
[Music]
[Applause]
do you wear clothes do you want to like
them
uh i i will wear clothes and you like
them
yeah i really like these outer known
clothes they send me
then i think like the there are a couple
of things i like about them
number one is they actually feel high
quality like you know
it's better than than the usual um off
the rack stuff
uh and i i have to say the fact that
kelly slater the pro surfer and eleven
time world champion
uh is behind this line actually just
makes me feel cooler like i feel like
i've got a little bit more
surfing coolness uh in my
life just by wearing these clothes and i
know they were made
in a responsible way it wasn't like you
know little kids getting their
knuckles broken or anything um so
if you want to check out these clothes
uh that are made responsibly uh they
look great they feel great go to
outernoon.com
today and enter my code yang at checkout
and you'll get 25 percent off your full
price order
that's out of known.com
o-u-t-e-r-k-n-o-w-n-dot-com
and remember to use my code yang at
checkout for 25 off
check them out today i don't know.com
promo code yang
25 off you're gonna like them a lot
do you think this is the easiest ad we
record i think it is because i actually
wear this stuff
and like i recommended it to friends off
the show
i don't know this and this is one of the
this is one of the easy ones i think
totally i get compliments on them too
yeah i love this stuff
check it out i don't know.com 25 off
it's fantastic
check them out audinoon.com use promo
code yang
[Applause]
so i i did not dwell that much on my
identity throughout my campaign
but i think that there's something to be
said about having like a
different take on some of these issues
that isn't from one of like these
traditional camps
if you will you know like i came in
and talking about some of these problems
and solutions
in a way that again was just natural to
me and this is who i was um but then
it kind of took some of the venom out uh
because instead of my being like hey
you know like these people that blame
throw rocks at them or these people to
blame i was just like trying to
focus on a fix and how do you think your
identity plays into that
well i think part of the part is like
i'm the son of immigrants so like a lot
of people talk about how their family
goes back
like you know very very far it's like my
family just got here you know like
i was like around being like what like
there's a problem okay
let's do something about that and then
so there there was like this
um you're not invested in all the
reasons to not
fix it yeah like i don't know you know
and
and
there there was like this lack of
judgment associated uh
for for me too where it's like you know
like
has like some very very dark [ __ ] up
[ __ ] happen in american history like
various people in various groups because
of that anything like 100
yes but you know um but i'm not here to
like
you know like i'm i'm gonna try and like
uh
just like address what we can address
here in 2019 or 2020 or whatever it is
whether it's healthcare and
alleviate poverty like do things that
are
to me long overdue but packaged in a way
that isn't
necessarily um like freighted
uh i i suppose i think there were there
were
i think there was that was also built
into my campaign in a way i didn't
realize
um and the way you're describing
how we can try and package some of these
ideas
it is fascinating to me on on how like
the message and the messenger get like
wrapped up in each other um in this
space
like it's funny it's like we almost need
like a different sort of human
to be delivering some of these messages
um and then our politics gets bound up
with like who the messenger is at all
times and then like the
political class descends on it being
like oh you know we have a black
candidate in like this
community like doing this and then like
then that becomes
like the like a big part of the story
and in my case
like in my opinion there was no story
around the asian
american candidate making this case
because asian americans just aren't
supposed to be part of this particular
story so that there was like a there was
like a giant like
collective shrug from like the meteor
political class
because it was like well this is not
part of our pre-big narrative so
uh best to ignore it's really
interesting you know i
my my experience from just as a writer
is a little bit different i mean maybe
someone may be different which is
i feel like part of the you know that we
that there's so much talk about indian
americans
um asian americans in general in many
cases
serving playing this role of the model
minority and
and the ways in which our communities
um have often been
used the stories of our communities
first of all misleading stories because
there's actually a lot of poor
indian-americans and a lot of poor
chinese-american it's not these are not
like monolithically successful
communities but they're
above average successful in many
indicators
but the ways in which these communities
have been and the stories of them have
been exploited
to justify uh you know
austerity and lack of compassion for
other communities right like
the the crudest version is like and
people have you know
said this openly like if indian
americans can
achieve what they have in america then
what excuses do african americans have
or others and this kind of
awful reasoning that people engage in um
and so for me a lot of my coming to
consciousness around
the issues we've been talking about is
getting to a place of being comfortable
not playing the role that i'm supposed
to play because of my identity
and i don't know if you feel that also
but to me part of the role i'm supposed
to play
as a as an indian american who's been
whose family has been fortunate in
america who's been personally fortunate
is like you're supposed to shut up about
all the other stuff right like because
you got let through like you got led
into the good part of the nightclub
and why would you explain it's one
reason why your
uh your arc from that lunch
in aspen to now i think is so important
and awesome
uh i don't i actually think that like
the part you're supposed to play
is the person who's uh
able to point out the things that for
whatever reason
other people who have been on the inside
aren't willing to talk about
so for what it's worth i think that's
actually your role but i i and i feel
that very strongly now too and i will
still
when i tweet some of these things people
in india
in the global world that is twitter
people in india will be like dude
what are you doing like your family went
over there like you've benefited
from america like why are you
criticizing it of course white people
say that to me all the time and tell me
to go back to my country but even people
in india are like why are you
complaining about that system
it's so much better than our system you
all went over there
and i think part of what i came to is if
you are
lucky enough to have this system work
for you
what you should do is not assume you're
the rule
but assume until proven otherwise you're
the exception
and look at the ways in which this
country
is not serving but frankly has never
served
very large numbers and communities of
people
um and it took me time to kind of
see that as you say the actual
logical end point of my family's
immigration journey and good fortune is
to
[Music]
talk about the deficiencies
of the country they found and and this
is very important
to treat the centuries-long
you know debts of this country and
depredations of this country as my
personal problem
and not as something that happened
before my time you know there was this
fascinating notion in
debate in germany a few years ago where
you had
[Music]
you had these protests i forgot the
larger issue they were they were
protesting
and you started to have what in germany
there's obviously particularly
sensitivity around which is chance of
jews go home or similar
anti-semitic chants at these protests in
germany and you know
hate speech this guy is actually illegal
in germany because of its history
but what emerged in this particular case
a few years ago that a lot of people
doing the chanting
were not white neo-nazis but were
relatively new muslim immigrants um
small numbers of them hardly represented
but but the people who happen to be
doing these chances
were coming at it from a you know
a different history a non-german history
of anti-semitism and so there was this
debate in germany
that unfolded of like well these guys
just got here
like should they be you know like
they didn't murder jews in the holocaust
like should they be bound
by the same weight of history should
they be judged by the same state
and and this guy wrote this really
powerful piece i think was a journalist
a very powerful piece saying the only
way we can do this is
from the moment you come to this country
germany in that case
whether you're been here a long time or
whether you're immigrating now the
refugee
in some ways you assume
the assets and the debts
of that society right you don't get to
just start
at the moment you're starting and that
even you know refugees arriving here
from the most precarious situations
for better or worse assume
the historical debts of germany they're
you're now part
of it wasn't like certain people only
and i thought that was a very powerful
argument i think it it taught me
something just about immigrant
people more generally well it's
something that i felt very strongly
uh where my parents came here create a
better life for me and my brother i grew
up
in imbibing american culture and i love
this country and i think that
the act to improve it is an act of
patriotism
uh which is what you've been doing and
exercising like i don't see your
critique as like somehow like
bad i mean it's good for the country
it's like you need someone to point out
like hey things have
been going wrong in a very serious way
uh
and um you're a parent i'm a parent i
mean our kids are growing up in this
country like
you know we have to do what we can for
this land of ours
uh so i completely agree with you that
there's like an inheritance
in part because i at least from my
perspective it's like i owe this country
so much
that if i can give back in some way then
like i'll be
100 willing to to do all i can
because my parents bet on this country
like you know defines who i am and has
defined all of the
great things in my life my wife my kids
uh
in like uh i i'll say this and i think
this is true for you too it's like i
took the ideals of this country to heart
growing up you know it's like you you
learn all these things about america
growing up and then you find that you
know they're real problems
and then to me my running for president
was like okay
we can fix these problems and it's like
it's not like let's like
i mean we don't have a choice really
because we're all here we have to do all
we can
um so i see your
your actions your writings your
behaviors are really like as
deeply patriotic i'm i'd like to me
anyone who doesn't see that
is mistaken well thank you that's this
is why i refuse to go back to my country
of
uh cleveland ohio because i you know the
dissent is patriotic as they say and and
and i think you know though we work in
different ways i think what we share is
a sense that
you know if uh if a
fortunate uh asian-american young man
is expected to primarily show up with
gratitude
a kind of silent gratitude i think in
our own ways we've rejected
that as the soul posture or the dominant
posture i am grateful
but i'm now more conscious than
than ever maybe more conscious than i
was you know
growing up um about
all the people in this country my family
chose that
that are not um that have never availed
of of this kind of
fortunate story well i it's one of the
reasons why i think that
our conversation around how we can help
frame these ideas in different ways is
so important not on because
like i think that this country needs us
to try and frame some of the big
solutions in ways that are
more translatable to more people i did
not realize setting out that that was
going to be something that
like i i thought that i could lend a
hand to too but now i believe
it and it's even more true for you
because you're more of a crafter of
words than i am
you know you're like a real like a real
person who uh grapples with ideas uh
as your your
core passion and job in a way that like
i'm
more of a blunt instrument
[Laughter]
the blunt force of math this happened
yes
like let's go make this [ __ ] happen like
what do i need to do run for president
what are the rules okay
like let's go do it so if anyone can
help frame some of these ideas in
different terms so that we can get more
people on board
it's you well um
i think uh we have a lot of work to do
we have a lot of work to do
ana this was so much fun like i would
we'll i know this you know at this point
we we were
at the tail end of this conversation but
like i enjoyed this so much we should do
this all the time because
like i feel like i would just learn so
much uh and you know hopefully you
enjoyed it have as much as i did
this is great i haven't had such a good
conversation in part because of the
pandemic but also because this is a
really great conversation
in a very long time so thank you so much
for uh for for
spending uh spending the time you
kidding thank you man all the best to
you and your family and hopefully we'll
see each other in person
uh uh you know as opposed to the zoom
yeah absolutely stay safe man
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yangspeaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you